ashle ate one slice of cake and  Kristopher ate one slice of cake if  there were initially five slices what  fraction of the cake was eaten  so the fraction fraction eaten the  fraction of the cake eaten is going to  be the number of slices that were eaten  number of slices eaten divided by the  total number of slices the total the  total number of slices that were there  initially so what is the number of  slices that were eaten Ashleigh ate one  christopher ate one so it's going to be  this one plus this one so it's gonna be  one it's going to be two slices that  were initially eaten so if we take these  two together we know that two slices  were initially eaten and then what were  the total number of slices would they  say there were initially five slices  there were initially five slices so what  fraction of cake was eaten two-fifths